[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Thanks so much.
That was quite the introduction.
Thanks, everyone, for coming
today, and thank you to Google
for hosting us and Sam
for being our host today.
We really appreciate it.
As many of you are
probably aware,
since 1990, over
a billion people
have moved out of
poverty globally,
which is really
exciting, and I think
gives us all the idea
that it's possible
and that we can make significant
progress on our goals
towards ending global poverty.
At the same time,
nearly a million people
still live in
poverty and many more
than that live without
access to financial services,
live without access
to health, and live
in chronic and acute hunger.
And those people are
disproportionately
women and people
living in rural areas.
And so at Grameen
Foundation, we're
really committed to
continuing to find solutions
that work for those people.
Many of the advances that have
driven the reduction in poverty
have been global growth.
But there are also
many advances that
have been due to investments
and development initiatives.
So, for example, in
India, some of you
may know the Aadhaar
system, which
is the new national identity
and biometric system in India.
Some of you may
have worked on it.
But India has made a
significant investment
in making sure that
every person in India
has a national ID, that that
national ID is connected
to their biometrics so that
they are able to access that
at any time.
National identity is
a significant issue
for poor people.
Many of them don't
have identity.
They don't have a
birth certificate.
They don't have any sort of
government documentation.
And without that,
they're significantly
limited in their
ability to open a bank
account, in their ability to
access government services,
in their ability to be
recognized, in their ability
to vote.
And so for India
making the commitment
to establish this
national identity
and connecting it
to biometrics has
been a significant investment
and a significant advancement
towards their end to poverty.
Once people are in
the system, they're
able to access their
government benefits.
They all automatically
have a bank account
that's opened for them.
So their government
benefits transfer directly
from the government
into their accounts
without having to pass through
other hands, which makes sure
that they receive all
of their benefits.
The development of that system
was a development initiative.
It was funded by the Gates
Foundation in collaboration
with the Indian government
and many other development
initiatives.
Another one, which many
of you may have heard of,
is M-Pesa in East Africa,
which is a mobile money
system connected to the
Vodafone system there.
So, although only 15% of Kenyans
have a bank account, over 90%
of Kenyans use a mobile
money account connected
to their mobile phone.
And randomized controlled trials
have verified that over 6%
of people annually move out of
poverty because of their access
to mobile money.
And there are several
reasons for that.
One is that it increases
their resilience.
If somebody has a health
emergency, for example,
they're able to reach
out to friends and family
near and far to see if they
can gather resources to cover
that health emergency rather
than having to sell off,
say, a productive asset
in their household,
having to sell a cow,
which may be worth $100,
just to pay for a $6 health
emergency, needing malaria
medication, for example.
So they're able to
increase their resilience
through their social networks
through the mobile money
platform and able to retain
more of their assets.
For women, it's an
important resource too.
They're able to save and
save somewhere often that
is more private
and away from, say,
their husband or
other family members
who may want access
to their resources.
So for women in particular,
having a safe and private place
to save is a very important
part of their ability
to have more control
over their own resources.
We live in amazing times,
and with this technology
development, much
of it happening here
at Google and many
of you, hopefully,
involved in some of it.
We're seeing big data,
the use of cell phones,
being part of just a host
of disruptive technologies
that are transforming the
way we work in the developing
community, the way that
we engage with partners,
and giving us really
unprecedented opportunities
to make impacts on poverty.
At Grameen Foundation,
we're really
passionate about
disrupting global poverty.
We're working to
create breakthroughs
that will reach many of those
still living in poverty.
We design strategies that
equip women and their families
with knowledge and services.
We really look at how we engage
with frontline workers, people
who are already engaged
with poor households,
to improve their
ability to deliver
products and services to them.
And we bring together
partners in an ecosystem.
So we work primarily
with software companies,
with private sector
entities, with governments,
to ensure that
solutions we develop
are embedded in sustainable
delivery mechanisms,
whether that's
sustainable private sector
initiatives or sustainable
government initiatives.
Many of you may know
Grameen Foundation--
let's see.
I think I got ahead of
myself on the slides--
through our history.
We were founded in
1997 through the work
of Muhammad Yunus, a Nobel
Laureate for his work
as the father of microfinance.
His breakthrough idea was
really that poor women
were someone you
could invest in,
that you could lend to them.
They would invest that
money in their businesses,
and then they would repay it.
And we really have grown
on the back of that idea
that poor households are
good investments and someone
you can do business with.
In our first 10 years, we
really focused on microfinance
and developing microfinance
institutions globally.
But in the last 10 years, we
have built on that foundation.
We've really focused on
using digital technology
to develop sustainable solutions
to reach the poor, especially
women.
Today, our mission is both
urgent but also hopeful.
It's urgent because 60% of
the chronically hungry people
are still women and girls.
They are
disproportionately affected
by poverty and global hunger.
Though global poverty
is on the decline,
global hunger is on the rise.
Two billion people, more
than half of them women,
have no access to formal
financial services,
which is a key enabler to life.
More than 100 million people are
driven into poverty every year
because of a health crisis.
And that's not a developing
country phenomenon alone.
That's a phenomenon
right here in the US.
And maternal mortality
rates in Africa
remain virtually unchanged
over the last three decades.
So there is an urgent
need to continue
to invest in finding
solutions to global poverty.
At the same time, we're hopeful
digital technologies are
offering unprecedented
solutions, things
like human-centered design
and private sector's increased
focus on working with
the extremely poor,
provide opportunities that
we've never had before.
Looking forward,
Grameen Foundation
is looking to reach 25 million
people over the next 25 years
and move them sustainably
out of poverty.
Today, we work in
three main areas.
We work in digital financial
services for women.
We work in digital
innovations in agriculture.
And then we work in health
financing and access.
Health financing and
access is primarily
connected to our
work, particularly
around financial
services and agriculture.
I wanted to highlight a
couple of our programs
that I thought you guys might
be particularly interested in.
The first one is
called the CAN network,
with the Community Agent
Network in the Philippines.
I think everybody is familiar
with the Philippines.
It's an island nation.
It's made up of over
7,000 islands, which
makes it extremely expensive
and time consuming for people
to access financial services.
And it makes it extremely
expensive for financial service
providers to build
out infrastructure
across all of those
7,000 small islands.
So we have worked
with women like this,
with Joan, what are called
sari-sari shop owners, kiosk
owners.
They run little,
small businesses.
They sell daily household items.
And we have worked with
a technology provider
to equip these
women with what we
call a point-of-sale or POS
device that enables them
to do mobile money
and digital payment
transactions for members
of their communities.
So now Joan, who is on a small
island in the Philippines,
is able to be the intersection
point for her island
and for her community for people
to pay their electricity bill,
for people to make a
deposit or a withdrawal
into their bank account.
And this is enabling
financial inclusion
to reach these small
islands and people who've
never had access to it before.
To date, we've trained over
1,800 agents, 75% of them women
like Joan.
We cater to 423
low-income neighborhoods
across this island nation.
We've facilitated over
4.3 million transactions
valued at 1.3 billion pesos.
So there was a huge unmet
demand for these types
of digital financial
services, and as soon
as we were able to put an access
point in these communities,
you saw the amount of people who
were using digital mobile money
really ramp up.
The other project
we're engaged in,
which I thought you guys
might find interesting,
is a project we call
Set for Farming.
It's a project that
just launched this year,
and it's part of our global
partnership with Mars,
which is the chocolate company,
makes most of our candy bars
these days.
And in this project, we use
satellite digital imagery
and data to reach 240,000
smallholder cacao farmers
across Ghana to help them
increase their yields,
improve their incomes, and
build stronger businesses.
The way we do this is
taking some of the precision
farming techniques that
have been developed
in the developed world for
use on large-scale farms
and large industrial
farms and try and take
some of those technologies and
those techniques and make them
work for smallholder farmers.
So things like satellite imagery
to help understand whether--
sorry-- soil conditions
and whether soil
needs additional
nutrients, to understand
if your farm needs
more or less water
during any particular
point of view.
You can use satellite
data imagery
to understand whether the
pruning on a particular farm
has been done correctly.
And weirdly, pruning is very
important for cacao trees
and helps improve
their productivity.
So making sure that
it's done correctly
is an important thing.
So we work with Mars and
some of their partners
on the ground who have
these field agents--
extension agents we call them--
who already go out and
interact with the farmers.
So we're able to use satellite
imagery and satellite
data to provide information
to the extension agents
so that when they go
out and visit a farmer,
they can tell him, you need
to improve your pruning
techniques.
We can see that your trees
need to be pruned more.
We can see that your
soil is low in nitrogen,
and you need to plant
additional plants in order
to increase the
nitrogen in your plants.
And so it's really taking
that technology that's already
in use for these
large-scale farms
and figuring out
how we can use it
to increase small-scale farmers
productivity and their income.
And many people don't realize
that cacao farmers are
some of the poorest
people in the world,
even though they're connected
to this global chocolate value
chain.
There are high levels of child
labor in chocolate globally.
And so part of this
work that we do
is not only improving
their productivity
but bringing these farmers
into a global digital system.
So their information gets
into our system for each farm,
their farming practices,
et cetera, and then
we are able to work with them
to become fair trade certified,
to become organic
certified if that's
what they're looking for.
So it's a system that gives
both greater profitability
to the farmer but also greater
visibility for all of us
into the global
chocolate value chain.
And it's something that
we're working with Mars
and looking at blockchain
as the next part of that,
so that as consumers,
everybody can have visibility
into how your chocolate
products through Mars
are being produced, and whether
they're fair trade certified,
whether they're absent of
child labor, et cetera.
So I know that that's something
that both sides of the coin
can benefit from.
One cornerstone that's
consistent across all
of our projects is our desire to
really use data and information
to track our programs.
We're, I think in the
developing community,
still at the nascent
stage of figuring out
how to use big data and some
of these big data sources
to really bring to the fight
against poverty and hunger.
But we're trying to use these
smart tools and the data
and the information that we
have on smallholder farmers
to bring them more fully
into market systems
and to overcome some
of their challenges.
One of the things, for
example, that we're
looking at doing
now, we have worked
with hundreds of thousands of
smallholder farmers globally.
One of the biggest
constraints that they all have
is access to
finance because they
don't have a financial history.
Many of them don't
have bank accounts.
Many of them haven't worked
with a mainstream or large
financial institution before.
They made do all of their
lending and borrowing
locally through their community
or through money lenders.
So how can we help
this data that they've
built up in our system?
We may have three to four years'
worth of their farming data.
We may know exactly
how much they've
spent, invested in their farm.
We may know exactly how
much they've produced
and what they've earned off
of that production for two
or three years.
So how can we help
them take that data
and turn it into a credit
profile or a credit score
that they can then use
with the mainstream
financial institution?
So we've already done
some of that in Colombia
with coffee farmers,
and we're looking
to replicate it in Uganda
with coffee farmers
and then in Ghana, in
[INAUDIBLE],, with these cacao
farmers.
So we think that's
something very exciting
and a real growth area for us
and an area where we can really
use the data that we already
have to really make an impact.
I think there's
other exciting ways
we can start to think about
using technology globally
to alleviate poverty.
I talked about blockchain.
It's something that we're
all trying to figure out
what the best way to use is--
this new technology--
and ways that it
can help impact poverty.
One of the ways that we're
thinking about at Grameen
Foundation is particularly with
refugees, as they cross borders
and are receiving
health care, say,
in a country that
is not their own,
how can they develop a
health record on something
like blockchain that helps
them as they move globally,
whether they repatriate
to their home country
or whether they're moved
onto a third country?
How can they take their
health records with them?
Something like blockchain
is something that can really
be very helpful with that.
We're experimenting with
artificial intelligence
and augmented
reality, particularly
in our India office.
We've been working with
Accenture Development Partners
and using artificial
intelligence.
For example, we do a lot of
financial literacy training,
so using artificial
intelligence to help us
understand how much women have
understood and internalized
the training that
they've received
and where women need
additional support
to ensure that
they understand how
to use financial
services appropriately.
So I've actually done it
myself, done the little Q&A,
and it's very interesting
to get the read out
and the report on
how you're doing
and how well you're
understanding the lessons
that you've just received.
So it's exciting.
And another exciting
area we're looking at
is remote sensing for
agricultural irrigation.
So, again, it's
something that's being
used by large-scale industrial
farms in developing countries,
but can we use remote sensing
to help smallholder farmers
in India use water
more efficiently
and water more effectively?
So that's a project that we're
just at the beginning of.
So I'm going to
end it with that,
and I'm really happy to answer
any questions anybody has
or talk a little bit
more about our work.
We at Grameen are very
excited about the ability
to use technology and
information to end
extreme poverty and hunger.
We think these can help
create the breakthroughs that
will move women and their
communities out of poverty
in a sustainable way.
And we think it can be
helped with the work
that people at Google are doing.
So we're really excited to
talk with you guys today more
about the work we're
doing and hear more about
if you guys think you're working
on anything that's relevant
or could be adapted.
We're really excited
to hear about it.
I will say that my
colleague, Bee, is over here.
So if you want to sign
up for a newsletter
to learn more about
Grameen Foundation,
she's the one to see.
But with that, I'll end and see
if anybody has any questions.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious about where
you see the intersections of
Google's work and development,
so anti-poverty or anti-hunger
efforts or job training
or other significant
efforts that will have
an impact on social well-being.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I feel,
probably Google.org
[INAUDIBLE] philanthropic
arm, because they
work with non-profits
and [INAUDIBLE] I mean,
she really understand
a lot about that.
But I think that this--
actually, I met with
Jacqueline in Reno last week.
So I think that they definitely
are a good point of contact.
The only things that
we are working--
or, myself, I work in
Google Developer Relations.
We deal technology, and
we work with developers.
And we have these trainings
around the world that
focus on social impact,
because, of course,
we work with big
companies all over.
But this is based
on social impact,
and we are part of
Grow with Google, which
is becoming a global initiative
in the US, Europe, India,
Indonesia, recently launched
in Africa as well in Nigeria
in Google for Nigeria.
So, in addition to these
developer trainings,
we do internet in railway
stations, digital skills
training, many of the things
that you were talking about.
I mean, just getting people
increase their ability
to get employed.
And that's what we do.
So, of course, we are part
Google cloud platform,
which all the technology is
there in terms of whatever.
We have the cloud.
So interesting, I
mean we can probably
follow up and see
if we can figure out
if we can collaborate
in some way or another.
Thank you.
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Yeah, thanks.
That would be very exciting,
I think, especially
with some of the
skills training pieces.
That's something that we're
always being asked for.
AUDIENCE: Do you see the problem
of global poverty getting worse
with desertification
and lost variable land,
basically due to global
warming and climate change?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Absolutely, and I
think it's very
geographically specific.
And there are parts
of the world that
are being impacted differently.
So, for example, you see
areas like Mozambique
or the Philippines that are
being subjected to much more
frequent natural disasters.
So Mozambique, for example,
is much more frequently
being hit by typhoons or
significant rains that
are causing flooding, that
are causing crop loss, that
are causing loss of life.
So we're seeing those
issues hit some countries.
At the same time, we're seeing
other countries, particularly
the Sahel region
countries, where
increasing desertification
is encroaching
on areas that were
former breadbaskets
and that were producing
significant amounts of food.
So there are different
impacts everywhere.
But, without a doubt,
particularly the developing
world is being
disproportionately impacted
by climate change.
And they are disproportionately
not contributing
to climate change.
AUDIENCE: I guess the
question to the foundation
is, are you doing
anything to try
to prevent that from happening?
Is it easier to prevent people
getting into poverty because
of this than trying
to pull them out of it
afterwards, after the fact?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So one of the projects
we've initiated,
for example, in the Philippines
is an early warning system.
So it's both a weather and
a pest early warning system.
So one of the things we're
seeing with climate change
is very different pest
patterns globally because--
and mosquitoes are one
that a lot of people--
it's not a crop
pest, but mosquitoes
are coming into areas
that they've never
been before because the climate
in that area has changed.
So, similarly, with
crop-related pests,
they are coming into areas
where they've never been before,
where farmers don't know how
to deal with them, as well
as weather-related
risks, particularly
in the Philippines.
So in the Philippines
we've worked
with both the Ministry
of Agriculture
and a local university
that runs the weather
stations in the country to
develop an early warning
system.
So that early warning system
sends information to farmers
if there's an
inclement weather event
or if there's a pest
outbreak in their area.
And not only does it tell
them about the event,
but it gives them instructions.
So, for example, if
there's a typhoon coming,
it may tell farmers, you need
to cover your trees in burlap.
It may tell them, you
need to harvest early
because there'll
be total crop loss.
You should harvest
what you can now.
At the same time, it allows
for two-way communication.
So, say, a farmer finds
a pest in their crop
that they're not familiar with.
They can take a picture of it.
They can send it
into the system.
They can receive information
back on what to do about it.
But at the same time,
it will triangulate.
So if several farmers in an
area report the same pest,
it will then send out a warning
to all farmers in the area
that the pest has been
spotted in their area
and how they should
treat for it.
So early warning
system is something
that we're working on that we've
piloted in the Philippines.
We're working on integrating
it into this Ghana
project I was talking
about and other projects.
So, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAUREN HENDRICKS: So that
may have been way more detail
than you wanted.
AUDIENCE: That was perfect.
AUDIENCE: Can I add to
that a little bit as well?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: So farmers are the
majority of the world's poor.
70% of the extreme
poor are farmers.
So a lot of what
we do is in terms
of helping those farmers
increase their productivity
and the sustainability
of what they do,
which is part and parcel of
adjusting to climate change.
So I don't know if
you want to maybe talk
a little bit about the
savings groups work,
like in Burkina Faso and how
we're directly doing that.
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think climate
adaptation is a big issue.
And it's both a financial issue,
and it's an agricultural issue.
So in Burkina Faso, we
work with women who--
and a lot of times,
particularly in Africa,
you'll see that men
are often engaged
in what we call cash crops.
So they grow a crop that
can be sold at market,
and women are engaged
in household food crops.
And so we engage women in
Burkina Faso in savings groups.
So they get together
on a regular basis.
They save weekly, usually
a very small amount,
and they're able to
pool that savings.
Then they can borrow from it
if they need for an investment.
But at the end of
the year, then they
receive their savings back, and
they're able to invest in it.
So as part of that project,
we worked with those women
on understanding the impacts of
climate change in their region
and helping them
to modify or adapt
what crops they're growing.
So we've worked
with a lot of women,
for example, to start
growing cowpeas or cassava
and different kinds
of orange yams, which
are much more drought
resistant and tolerant,
given the changes
that are happening.
A lot of times what
happens, particularly
in these rural
communities, is that people
have been engaged for
generations in farming
a certain type of crop, and they
really understand that crop.
And as climate change
happens, and they
need to move into
crops that are going
to be more appropriate,
given what their new climate
reality is, they don't
have that level of skill
and understanding of that crop.
And so helping them have the
information on what crops
are going to work for them now
and how they should grow it
and how to harvest
it, et cetera,
is an important
part of our work.
And then making sure they have
the resources to invest in it.
It's very risky for
smallholder farmers.
Cassava is one of the things
I dislike most in this world,
because it's a very
drought-resistant crop,
and it grows almost everywhere.
So a lot of people
have a lot of incentive
to grow cassava because it
will come in no matter what.
And you will be able to
feed your family on it.
It is a very low-nutrient--
cassava's like a
yam, a yellow yam.
But it doesn't have the
nutrients that yams do.
And particularly, for young
children, it's hard to digest.
So you see young children
who eat a lot of cassava
actually tend to be
more malnourished, even
though they're getting
a lot of calories--
because they can't
digest them very well.
They tend to be
extremely malnourished.
But people plant it
because it fills bellies.
And so if we can give
people the information
they need on other crops that
will do as well as cassava
but will have much more
nutritional benefit
for the household, like yellow
and orange sweet potatoes,
like cowpeas, which are
extremely drought resistant.
If we can help them to
understand these new crops
that they can be using,
which are readily
available in their areas,
and how to harvest them,
not only will they potentially
have a better harvest,
but it will be more
nutrient rich food for them.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about mobile financial services
and device security.
A lot of these cheaper
Android devices
basically never get
security updates.
Have you found any practices
that help protect people
if they're acting as
the financial agent
for their whole village of
keeping their device secure?
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Yes.
I would say that device
security is probably
pretty low on a lot of
people's priority lists.
What is high, and where I think
we're seeing a lot of momentum,
is moving people towards
more and better smartphones.
So you see a lot
of people still--
most people,
particularly in Africa,
are still using--
well, Africa, India,
most development countries are
still using feature phones.
So the big push is to try and
get people onto smartphones
and to get people
more access to data.
Because even when people
move to smartphones,
data can be very
expensive still.
So the short answer
to your question
is, not really doing a
lot on device security.
AUDIENCE: Are
feature phones more
resistant to malware than a
typical low-end smartphone?
AUDIENCE: I don't
know [INAUDIBLE]
LAUREN HENDRICKS: I don't
know the answer to that.
My guess would be yes,
only because it doesn't
have very many features.
They don't have very
many features for people
to mess with.
And usually, then, when
you're using a feature phone,
you're using USSD
or SMS technology
to access your accounts
or do your transactions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was curious
about something you
said about using blockchain
for medical records.
I was curious what makes
that technology specifically
suitable for that purpose
versus some other database
platform or some other system.
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Yeah, I think one
of the things that
makes blockchain
interesting in that
particular use case--
and it's one we're
still exploring.
We haven't implemented yet--
is the ability for those
records to be transferable
across borders and to be
accessible through biometrics.
So if a person returns
to their home country,
a lot of times when
refugees cross borders,
they don't have
documentation with them.
So they don't have their
national IDs, et cetera.
So the ability to build
biometrics into that
and to make it accessible
when people cross borders
are what makes blockchain
particularly interesting
in a lot of these cases.
I think a lot of people are
very bullish on blockchain--
and I'm also bullish
on blockchain--
but I think people want
to use it a lot of times
when you could just
use a regular database.
And so I've heard
people tell me,
even if it's just
a regular database,
go ahead and put it in
blockchain because that's
where the world is moving.
And then other people have said,
it's a complicated technology.
If you could just use a
database, just use a database.
So we're probably
still on the just use
a database side of things.
People are thumbing
me up, so I'm
hoping that's the right answer.
AUDIENCE: I'll try and ask
loudly because the mic's
over there.
You talked about the amount
and the wealth of data
you guys have collected.
What's your view on
making that data publicly
available for people to
help you gain insights from?
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Yeah.
So I'll just repeat
it, in case--
the question was, because
we have such a large amount
of data, what our position
is on sharing that publicly,
which is a good question.
And I have a good answer,
because I was just
meeting with our tech
person this morning.
So we have a huge amount of
data in different systems.
So we're going through
a process right now
of cleaning that data.
I think we're very open to
sharing it in a couple of ways.
One, we're open to anonymizing
it and sharing it widely
so that people can
do research with it.
We're also open to
sharing it in ways
that allow people to provide
services to specific farmers.
So, for example, we have
a lot of data in Uganda,
and we are working
now actively on making
that accessible to
financial institutions
so that they can
identify farmers
who need to invest in their
farms and lend to them.
What we are quite
specific on is that that
needs to be a relationship
that the farmer understands
and agrees to.
Centenary Bank is one of
our partners in Uganda,
which is a large national bank.
So, say, Centenary Bank wants
to access a farmer's data
to see if they want to
make a loan to them.
The farmer either
needs to receive an SMS
and say, yes, I
consent to Centenary,
or the farmer needs to be
able to push their data.
So the farmers talk
to the Centenary Bank.
They want to send
them their data.
They can push it
from the system.
There needs to be a consent
process where the end user is
able to consent, because
when we originally
collected their data,
we didn't understand--
some of them may have
started five years ago.
We didn't know what we
could be doing with it.
They didn't consent at that
time to sharing it widely.
Going forward, we may have
different consent protocols.
But I think it's important.
And this gets back to the
blockchain thing a little bit.
Poor people don't
understand all of the things
you could be doing
with their data
and where their
data could be going.
And even if they
sign a consent form,
is that really
meaningful consent
if they don't understand
what we're all talking
about with this big data stuff?
And so how can you make their
data available but still
give them some level
of control over it?
We talked a lot
about, particularly,
because we work sometimes
in refugee situations.
What are people's
rights to anonymity,
right to be forgotten,
and what are
the dangers that go along
with people's data being
publicly available?
So, anyway, it's something
we think a lot about.
AUDIENCE: So I grew up
in farming in Florida,
and a lot of the industrialized
techniques that we had,
they made sense
because of economy
of scale and heavy equipment
and stuff like that.
How much of that industrialized
techniques, how many of those
apply, and have you
looked into any research
with more specific techniques,
smaller techniques?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
So that all depends.
And I'm going to say I'm
not an agriculture expert.
So things like data for
farming is something
that you can parse out
pretty easily and cheaply.
Other technologies like--
I don't know.
I'm trying to think.
There's a lot of work that's
been done, not necessarily
by us, but around cooperative
ownership of technology,
whether that
technology is a large--
what's the word I'm looking for?
AUDIENCE: Harvester.
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Harvester.
There we go.
Thank you.
Or other machinery.
Cooperative ownership
and cooperative movements
are big in developing
countries, as well as in the US.
But data I think
is something that
can be parsed out to
the individual farmers
so that they can
take action on it.
To add on to that, I do think
even in the developing world,
farm fragmentation is
an issue we deal with,
particularly because
of climate change,
as arable land is
shrinking in some areas.
You have a farmer.
He has so much land.
He has three sons.
It gets divided
among the three sons.
They have three sons.
It gets divided.
And so there is a
consolidation process
that needs to happen in
the developing world,
and it's a lot of what
we talk about and gets
to maybe some of the skills
training opportunities
because there needs to be
off-farm rural enterprise that
can pull labor off of
farms and allow for farm
consolidation in
a lot of countries
to make smallholding
farming more profitable.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
As somebody at Google
who mostly spends
time thinking about
consumer technologies
and sometimes enterprise
technologies in the development
world, I am curious
what you've seen out
in the developing world as far
as interesting or surprising
uses of technologies that
we've developed here,
big products like Gmail or
Android phones or-- contacts
and address book is
the area where I work.
What have you seen out there,
them using the products
that we've developed an
interesting and surprising
ways?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
That's a good question.
It was interesting.
I lived for seven
years in Tanzania.
I came home about two
or three years ago.
And I was amazed how many
people here don't use WhatsApp.
In East Africa, WhatsApp is the
primary mode of communication,
and WhatsApp is now
being used and piloted
for mobile money transfers.
So I think there's a lot
of interesting things
that are happening in
developing countries that
aren't happening here.
It's interesting, one of
those like aha moments for me.
I went to one of these women
savings groups in Kenya.
And we had worked with
them with a partner bank.
And they had a savings
account on their mobile phone
that they could deposit into.
So I was asking one of
the women in this group,
OK, you have a savings account.
What type of financial product
do you want next on your phone?
Do you want access to credit?
Do you want insurance?
Do you want agricultural credit?
She said, just put
them all on my phone,
and I'll decide
what I want to use.
So the hunger for
these tech solutions
is really, really high.
I talked to a woman same day
in a different group who said,
God I had to turn
Facebook off on my phone
because I was just
using it too much.
I had flown on an airplane
to a secondary city.
I had driven an hour.
I had taken a boat
across the lake
and gotten to this
rural community.
It was a four-hour
trek to get there.
And here's a woman telling
me I use Facebook too much
and I have to turn it off
because it's distracting me.
So the hunger for technology
is really, really high
in these communities.
And there's, I think, this myth
that a lot of these communities
aren't very tech savvy.
But they're really taking
up a lot of this technology.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, and I
have another question, too,
as long as I'm up here.
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Go for it.
AUDIENCE: So Google is full of
idealistic people with software
engineering skills.
If one of those
people, hypothetically,
wanted to put those skills
to work ending world hunger
or poverty, what are
the opportunities that
are out there on either a
volunteer or full-time basis
or whatever?
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
One of my colleagues
will be so excited
that you asked.
We have a program in
Grameen Foundation,
inappropriately named
Bankers Without Borders,
because it started
in our early days
when we were focused
primarily on microfinance.
But it is a volunteer
program that
lets working
professionals volunteer
their time, either
here from the US,
providing remote assistance,
or traveling to a developing
country to work with a local
partner for two to three weeks.
And so it's a volunteer program,
and we work with our partners
in developing countries who
have needs for assistance
and with professionals here
to try and match them up.
So if you see Bee, she'll
get you some information--
and anyone else who wants
to volunteer their time--
get you some information
on the Bankers
Without Borders program.
And you can sign up.
And some of it's as
un-time-consuming
as, say, we're working with
a small business in East
Africa that is
thinking about using
a technology in a certain
way, and they just
want to have a brainstorm
session with some people.
And so they'll set up
an ideation session,
Bankers Without
Borders will, and maybe
try and find five or six
professionals here in the US
or in Europe who can just sit
in on a Skype call or a WebEx
and talk through
with the CEO what
technology might fit his needs.
And then it could be
everything from we
have people who do
year-long fellowships funded
by their employers
to sit in a partner
and really work
with them in-depth
over the course of a year.
And then everything in-between.
So if you're interested
in volunteering,
definitely look at that
program and sign up for it.
It's really amazing.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
LAUREN HENDRICKS:
Thanks so much.
I'm going to let the
Google guy go first.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to understand what
parameters that you
look at on deciding
do you want to service this
country or this area or not,
because I'm sure
there's a lot of areas
that need your services.
How do you decide that?
LAUREN HENDRICKS: That's
a very good question.
I think one of the things
for Grameen Foundation
is that we are really looking
at sustainable solutions.
So we often have opportunities
to work on initiatives
that we think can benefit
maybe 10 to 15,000 people
but we don't understand
long term how
we would make that sustainable.
Could we embed it
in a government?
in a private sector?
For us, if we can't understand
the long-term sustainability,
it's a project that we
would probably pass up on.
And there are other groups
who could do that and maybe do
a good job, and
it has a benefit.
But our long-term DNA is
to look for something that
can be long-term sustainable.
We are an organization that
has a heavy tech history,
and so primarily, we're
looking at opportunities
where we can identify
ways to use technology
in ways that can maybe leapfrog
or find disruptive innovations
to solutions.
So that being said, it's
a case-by-case basis.
We almost always want a
local partner on the ground,
be that private sector,
government, or a local entity,
who can do the
implementation and who can
be the long-term owner of it.
AUDIENCE: And do the local
partners reach out to you as,
do they initiate
the first contact,
or do you see opportunities
and then reach out to the--
LAUREN HENDRICKS: That
really can depend.
Sometimes if we
have an opportunity,
if [INAUDIBLE]
puts out a call, we
may go out and look for
a particular partner.
Other times, somebody
might come to us and say--
So Musoni is a good
example of that.
They're the first all-digital
microfinance institution
in Kenya.
And so they came to
us saying, we really
want to build out an
agricultural financing product.
So can you help us
think through that?
So we worked with them, and
we had some BWP volunteers
who worked with them to
help think through what
an agricultural finance
product would look like
and how they could roll that
out across their organization.
And it's now become their
most profitable product.
So it works both
ways a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAUREN HENDRICKS: Thanks.
Thanks, you guys,
so much for coming.
I was really, A, worried
nobody would come,
and then worried nobody
would ask any questions.
So I really appreciate it.
Appreciate your time
and the work Google
is doing, because
I know many things
that you guys do are really
contributing to the work
that we do overseas.
So thanks so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]